[Applause]
I didn't wanna run
I don't want some ice on my wrist so I
look better when I dance have you
looking at it put you in a yeah yeah
[Applause]
minami my Rollie don't
keep stirring
yeah that way I need that blue lot by
Tuesday
yeah that way
[Applause]
from everybody and the ballroom
say Mandy Mandy
[Applause]
I loved is peppered in that awesome
performance we're some really great jazz
technical moments you had Padma raised
you have pirouettes you had a fan kick
those are hard to swag out I mean people
work their whole life to swag those
moves out and you guys did that tonight
[Applause]
we were very tough on you in your last
critique but you listened and you came
out and you said Val Mandy no I said
please don't do that
and you listened and you know what
there's nothing more that we could have
asked from you tonight
but you coming back from a hard critique
is what makes a champion I mean they
said it I don't know what to say except
for you can have my Rollie Rollie
maybe I'll hold on to it for now Oh No
[Applause]
yeah that's see that's 30 years of hard
work got it one day